many of you might be confused tonight
after a decision to overturn the
nationwide eviction moratorium
that judge is actually allowing the
moratorium to continue
while considering an emergency request
by the white house brian madison
kimbrough joining us live to tell us
what exactly is being discussed in the
renter's market
madison
yes while the eviction status of
nevadans across the
state is still unknown as you can see
we're in front of this apartment complex
it's clear that both the landlords and
the tenants are concerned
as the waiting game continues nevadans
still searching for answers as the
deadline for those living rent free will
come to an end may 31st
susie vasquez with the state apartment
association says this could take some
time
right now we're currently in a
wait and see period it could be
two weeks it could be six months the
eviction ban initially put in place last
year provides protection for renters
vasquez explains the difference between
the state and nationwide moratoriums
the state moratorium covers
more people from eviction
whereas the cdc order has certain types
of evictions that are protected governor
sisselek
is in control of the state moratorium
the cdc order does not affect that
however once governor siselek's eviction
moratorium
ends at the end of may then the cdc
order takes over until the end of june
realtor liz trujillo says the tenants
she works with are scared
tenants are struggling to know what's
going to happen
how are they going to qualify well this
person is going to
ask me to leave in 30 days and tenants
aren't the only ones struggling
landlords who welcomed the initial
decision made by the federal court on
wednesday
are just barely hanging on according to
vasquez
a number of landlords just like their
tenants are exhausting their
savings so there are quite a few
landlords that are looking
to potentially have to sell or foreclose
on their properties
now as of now renters still have until
the end of the month with the likelihood
of an extension
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now all right madison thank you for that